hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are chatting about iOS 10.3 but
really we're just gonna be covering one
of the most exciting things and that's
the find my ear pods feature what's
great about the final on-air pod feature
is if you lose one of them you'll be
able to ping the right or the left air
pod so hopefully you'll be able to find
it but unfortunately these guys don't
have GPS in them which would be an
incredible feature for Apple to put in
the future set of air pods that would
definitely take a tool on the battery
life of these but right now it's only
using bluetooth which means the range of
find my air pods is not very big so
really if you lose them and you're not
within range of your phone thank you you
know I can find they're gone I did a
video not too long ago about tile which
is sort of that same type of technology
you're basically using Bluetooth to find
your Bluetooth device if you're
wondering if that's not my dog right
there that's Coco so while my phone is
finishing setting up let's talk about
some of the things that are new in iOS
10 3 so previous to this update apples
using HFS which stands for hierarchical
file system and now they have moved over
to a new modern one because the previous
one was 31 years old which is originally
created for computers with floppy disks
which is kind of a crazy thought to
think about the new update is called
Apple file system a PFS for short so
this was originally I think announced
last year at WWDC so they're just now
integrating it into the 10-3 update
which is pretty exciting and it looks
like guess what my phone is ready baby
so we already talked about finding my
air pods and we're gonna try that out in
just a second power play update which I
am so excited about the carplay update
my old card never had carplay and my new
one does and it's super exciting I
talked about this in a previous video if
you guys want me to cover this more in
depth let me know what I will but it's
pretty cool it basically turns your
car's display into iOS and it integrates
pretty seamlessly my only complaint is
it doesn't use Google Maps so you kind
of have to use Apple maps if you're
going anywhere and you want to be using
GPS through your car it's also kind of
crazy because if you're wearing an Apple
car is telling you to turn left your
watch is telling you to turn left your
phone's going crazy it's a little
overkill but let me tell you what you're
not gonna get lost Siri support for
cricket scores in Indian Premier League
and I don't even
not sure what that is but I'm pretty
sure it's gonna be a good thing for
anybody that is in the cricket and from
India safari support for reduced motion
preferences new podcast app I don't
really listen to very many podcasts but
it's basically gonna be exactly like the
music app so if that's something you're
into then this is something you're gonna
be into this is kind of cool it's a new
system level way for developers to
request a prating opt-out option in
settings so if this has been kind of a
controversy in the App Store you leave
user reviews but then no one can really
respond back to them especially the
developer I feel like that's kind of a
big thing because a lot of people have
complaints or they have questions and
there's really no way to get in touch
with that set person so this is cool
carplay status and weather data and maps
app now has 3d touch forecast I don't
really use 3d touch that much do you
guys let's try out the air pods so let's
go into Find My iPhone which is where
that setting is so this is kind of cool
because it will show you on a map
exactly where your air pods are now I'm
curious to see if it'll stay there it's
sort of like a last scene place so as I
said at the beginning of this video you
are able to ping the left the left and
the right one separately so say oh
whoops
left fell out of my ear let's see if we
can find it and honestly this is kind of
loud so do not ping this while it's in
your ear so you click on play sound you
can mute the left or mute the right so
right now I'm gonna mute the right just
as I told you not to do that I did it
it's stupid okay so I'm gonna mute the
left okay they're both playing mute left
okay well left is still playing but I'm
pushing the button and nothing's
happening okay well they're both playing
but in theory that's what it's supposed
to do there's also a little car icon
here and you can click to drive to your
air pods
so that's interesting so I'm excited
that they have this feature because if
they are in your house and if they are
lost you hopefully will be able to ping
them and find them but it's really hard
because you've gotta be pretty close to
have the Bluetooth to work I use my
Apple watch a lot to try to find
but again also Bluetooth so unless I'm
sort of near it I can't find my phone
and then if I'm trying to find my watch
and I'm not near the watch and I'm
pinging it I'm like I can't find you so
that is a little bit of an issue but
honestly it's better to have this
feature and then not have it I don't
know if this would have helped me to
find my air pods before because I was
already at the airport when I realized
that I lost them let me know what you
guys think of the small yet sort of
pretty significant update 210 3 are you
guys gonna be using to find my ear pods
have you guys actually lost your ear
pods yet yeah and here's another thing I
feel like they're gonna have to change
the name of Find My iPhone app to find
my Apple device because looking through
here it's no longer fine just my iPhone
I've got my Apple watch air pods I have
my MacBook I have my Mac Pro tower phone
my iPad like it basically is your entire
life right here so it's not necessarily
fine my iPhone so I'm gonna be curious
to see what Apple actually does change
Find My iPhone to find my Apple device
well that's it guys I just wanted to
make a quick little video sometimes you
guys are like why do these little desk
videos not look very good I'm basically
just using my logitech webcam and a
microphone here I'm more or less care
about audio being pretty decent in these
videos because I'm usually just talking
over some screen cap it makes it so much
easier to do quick updates and then a
quick edit and get this out as quick as
possible and if you guys haven't seen
the video that I also posted this
morning it's pretty cool I made a video
making Zelda food in real life and it
was so much fun it also took me a really
long time to edit so go check it out
give it a like say you appreciate my
hard work editing Cheers up to the
freakin it's not even the weekend dozens
it's the weekend it's it's freaking
Monday geez so I'm gonna be making a me
skewer okay
pretty simple yeah and a spicy steamed
meat pretty simple glazed meat spicy
sauteed peppers sounds good and sneaky
meat and mushroom skewer don't really
know what that is but I'm excited to
find out